[Musique]
mais que vont dire de tout cela les
habitués des berges de la seine les
mères de famille qui venait y promener
leurs enfants les amateurs de solitude
et de tranquillité qui s'y reposer les
peintres les retraités qui venez flâner
avec leurs chiens les clochards et les
amateurs de bandes soleil à tous nous
avons posé la question que pensez vous
de la construction de cette voie sur
berge un peu moins agréable quand même
parce que il y aura beaucoup plus de
voitures il ya pas mal vous faire nous
rend encore plus ça fera du bruit c'est
dommage
s'ils reviendraient
pourquoi un autre quoi on change un
repas ça changera pas mais vous pourrez
plus dormir ici qu'ailleurs dans le
royaume ça manque de quoi maintenant
d'ici là lors de ma chambre
oh ben écoutez pour 55 prendre métro et
55 points pour le retour
c'est pas tellement cher on bat la
campagne avec la vie actuelle
ces portables seulement
risque de se sont reposés ont choisi la
scène
piron
votre vie un autre coin c'est très
difficile parce que
ok
comment seul et 30
je crois vous aurez du mal à ce
moment-là promener vos chiens bah oui ça
sera bien embêtant pour eux plus pour
nous aussi parce que c'était une petite
promenade assez pittoresque quand même
les quais de la seine c'est ce qu'il ya
de mieux et pêcheurs ont pas tout et
tout quoi en principe vous pourrez
continuer il restera un emplacement pour
les piétons a baissé à 10 a certainement
pas bien large avec les voitures qui
passeront ça sera bien délicat de les
laisser en liberté un mais vous avez une
voiture aussi
non monsieur mois ne rangez pas de
voiture et vous pourtant malgré votre
voiture vous êtes content
ah oui on va regretter je suis content
hélas toute la poésie 120 vous aimez ce
coin les berges de chanteurs ont été
rejetées paris je l'état depuis
tellement terni depuis avril inclus
pendant le cuir mais c'est le seul
endroit vous feront rêver
emma fallait semitan je donne une
famille quand vous êtes pour cette
autoroute
non je suis pauvre des gens comme
harrison
pour marissa tout détruit l'atmosphère
qu'il y avait avant tout est détruit
envoyait
n'est ce pas
habitué du poma a tout détruit
ce serait bien dommage
[Musique]